hey Luke here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and I've got an awesome
knife making video for you guys today
this video is all about experimentation
doing things I've never seen done before
trying things I've never done before not
being afraid to fail it's all the motto
of this video and I think you guys are
gonna absolutely love the results
[Music]
alright guys I've got this awesome
little piece of scrap leaf spring steel
leftover from a spear project I'm just
gonna make a little knife out of it man
I'm gonna do some cool things experiment
a little bit things gonna turn out
awesome but not overthinking it let's
just do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well kids remember don't text and forge
I got busy text messaging somebody and
melted my project right into luckily
it's where I was planning on cutting it
anyway so I think it's not fatal but
maybe I should put my phone down while
I'm heating
[Music]
[Music]
not looking too bad but I need to take a
little break I promised my wife I would
take her out tonight and I'm gonna do
just that but I am liking how this
projects turning out well guys evening
has fallen and it's time to pick up
where I left off I'm gonna keep grinding
on this get the profiles going then we
got a heat-treated and get the handle on
it
well that's not looking too bad let's
hit it with the finer grit and see what
happens
well now I need to get working on the
handle I'm gonna make a vocal gamma
handle mocha gamma is kind of like
Damascus only instead of using different
types of steel you're using copper and
nickel and so you take sheets of copper
sheets of nickel you Forge weld it into
a solid block and it makes this cool
wood pattern just like Damascus steel
except it's nickel and copper so to do
that I'm using a stack of quarters
quarters modern quarters anything after
I believe 1962 has a copper Center and
it's coated in nickel so here you have
nice little sheets of nickel and copper
well that's the theory any rate let's
see if I can do it
[Applause]
[Applause]
so there we go there's six moku gamma
billets
[Music]
[Music]
well that looks pretty ugly but
hopefully it'll polish up well
well guys it's getting a little late I
need to put my kids to bed so I'm gonna
put this down for the night but man I'm
it doesn't look too good right now we'll
see what happens when I get it all
ground out and polished up maybe it's
salvageable but I'm not too optimistic
right now well guys it's been a couple
days but I have some real concerns about
this mocha got a handle there are a lot
of delaminations and imperfections but
I'm not done grinding it yet so I'm
gonna get it shaped grinded then we'll
pass judgment on how it turned out
well that didn't turn out at all I mean
the more I ground away at this the more
delaminations popped up I think the
problem was I didn't clean the surfaces
enough whenever you forged weld
something you need to have very very
clean edges clean surfaces otherwise his
imperfections pop up and I was sloppy
with that and so I think in theory this
could work but instead of using coins
I'd use sheets of nickel and sheets of
copper and and then I would just be a
lot more careful for dwelling up and
making sure this edges were clean well
I'm disappointed to mukogawa didn't work
out but you know what I'm really digging
on this blade and I don't want to throw
it away I want to do something with it
so I'm gonna try something funky kind of
keep with this theme of trying new
things that I've never done before and
I'm gonna put a put a kind of a funky
handle on this thing and see how it
turns out
do you have an ID
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I've got the leather stacked up on
the handle as tight as I can and it's
pretty wet so I'm gonna stick it in the
oven and see if we can't dry it out
should take a bit quite a while to get
all this leather dried out because it's
you know there's moisture deep inside
there so this may take a few days well I
put the handle at the oven at about 300
degrees and that is to hot as you can
see it burned a little bit it's just
kind of superficial so I'm gonna cut
that part off and I think it'll be okay
but I turned it down to about 170 and
left it in for several hours and that
did just perfect then I let it dry
outside the oven for a couple days and
it seems really hard and tight and so
now we're gonna try to shape the handle
and I'm curious to see how it turns out
because I have never made a handle like
this yeah I think this is gonna work
it's coming out pretty good it's like
making gyro meat well there we go we got
it shaved up I think it's gonna work I
mean I may not have done a good job but
this is working hit it I think that
burning part it's gonna be a little
tricky alright guys I'm gonna try
grinding down this handle and shaping it
using the belt sander and I have no clue
how that's going to affect the leather
this might go really weird on us but
let's find out
well it smells like burning cattle and
there's this weird leather sawdust
everywhere but check that out that came
out really nice so that works pretty
well I think I'm gonna put a finer grit
on here and see if we can't polish it a
little bit well that actually worked out
pretty decent I'm pretty pleased with
that alrighty
well there we go not too shabby alright
guys it's been a few days and I'm gonna
keep working on the sheath here and
keeping in the theme of experimentation
I'm gonna insert a magnet inside the
sheet so the knife won't come out on its
own we're gonna see what happens I'm
gonna use this router here free hand to
try to carve out the space for the
magnet and the knife alright where'd you
go let that dry
there we go it's all dry now let's glue
this sucker
all right there we go
got that all glued up just let the glue
set and we'll be ready to rock and roll
the woods been drying for a couple days
let's get this shape
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the last things they need to do
is get rid of this claw in the end it's
just kind of an a nuisance it's really
pokey so I'm gonna go take care of this
there we go even blued it a little bit
on the end looks good now I think polish
is blade up a bit well guys my
experiment turned out pretty well I like
this really do I really like the handle
it is so comfortable I don't know how
well it'll hold up in the rain
maybe if I really coated in a lot of
beeswax it'll hold up okay but it is the
most comfortable handle I've ever I've
ever felt it's really great I think if I
ever get around to making a set of
carving knives I'll make a handle out of
this be perfect for carving tools the
magnet in the wood sheath is a brilliant
idea loving this and learned a few
things here and there I just had a great
time doing this project if you liked
this project and you liked what you saw
don't forget to click subscribe to the
outdoor boys YouTube channel we put out
new videos every week thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every week and
don't forget to hit that Bell button
you'll get notified when we put out
another great video